okay
standby i realize i didn't put the links
to both of these
hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom live stream sal here from khan
academy and
uh for those of you who are wondering
what this is
this is our way of of staying in touch
we started doing this as soon as we
started having
school closures i guess this is almost
three months ago now
uh and a way to stay connected and have
conversations that are relevant not just
for education in this
and the school closures in kovid but
frankly across a whole
a host of conversations and i'm looking
forward to the conversation that we're
going to have
uh shortly i do remind everyone we are
not for profit uh and we are funded with
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so
please think about making a donation i
want to give a special shout out to
several corporations that stepped up
especially when they saw that
we were already running at a deficit and
our costs have had only gone up
during the covid crisis bank of america
google.org
18t fastly and novartis and the many
other philanthropists
corporate partners we continue to run at
a deficit
but this makes a huge difference and
donations of all sizes
make make a big difference and allow us
to support
folks around the world especially those
who would not be in a position to
to have world-class resources
with that i'm excited to introduce our
guest
kristen deservo who is
khan academy's new chief learning
officer and i will remind everyone
you can put your questions in the under
fate in the facebook or the youtube
message boards and we have team members
who are going to be taking a look at
that
uh but kristin a great great to have you
here
thanks i'm excited to be here so what i
thought we could do is i'll start
just getting everyone acquainted on you
know learning science
and you know asking you questions there
but then i'd love to take as many
questions as possible from
uh the message boards because in the
past we've gotten a lot of questions
about what's the best way to study
and is you know what modality works or
what doesn't and
and you know i could obviously take
stabs at some of that but you are better
qualified
so let's just start off with a basic
question christian
what is learning science
so if you think about the two words
there fundamentally it's about trying to
use
scientific processes like the scientific
method to study
how we learn so what can we find out
about teaching and learning by
doing research it's actually kind of a
new
phrase a new domain that we talk about
because it doesn't it's not just about
educational psychology or cognitive
psychology but it also brings in
computer science and a little
anthropology
and thinking about classrooms as a whole
and also the technology that we bring in
so
it's a lot of kind of bringing things
together to think about how we can
improve
uh both educational technology but
generally our teaching and learning
and what we know about it by studying it
in a little more detail in depth
and what are you know as a learning
scientist and you've you know you've
done your phd and
what what are some things i mean just
you know high level before we even get
into
the some of the questions or uh you know
thinking about
what we're trying to do here at khan
academy but what are some of the big
ahas that you've had at least in your in
your learning science career
um i think there's a few so one is let's
talk about studying a little bit that
lots of people study
the wrong way ways that aren't really
helpful
so i know i spent a lot of time in
college you know
reading books with my highlighter out
and going through and then it's time for
the test and i go back and
go back and read all the things i
highlighted that's not really that
effective
much better to read a little bit close
the book
and explain to yourself what you just
read and say oh that relates to this
other thing that i know about and how
that fits
and then open the book back up and then
when you once you're done
close the book again and quiz yourself
because in fact
what you need to do on a test is
remember
information to bring information from
your memory back in
so that you can apply it and when you
quiz yourself that's what you're doing
if you're just reading and highlighting
that's actually not helping you do the
actual thing you need to do on the test
so lots of those things about just
thinking about
providing yourself explanations of what
you've just read and practicing
retrieving information from your memory
are much better for studying than
thinking about just watching things over
and over again
i know one thing that you do go ahead
no no as i say one thing that you do in
your videos a lot is you'll say
um pause the video and try to solve this
and i don't know how many people
actually do this but they should
because actually that's them trying to
actively do something with what you've
been explaining
and that's going to help them remember
it more no
i mean that's really interesting in a
lot of ways you validated
you know i thought i was a little bit of
a weird studier when i was in college
and in high school because i would
i would get frustrated because i could
see friends that could kind of just
power through a chapter in a dense
textbook and
you're exactly right they had the
highlight and i'm like oh i wish i could
be because i would like
read like three or four paragraphs and
then i would kind of
sit and ponder it for a little bit and
then i would
go back into it but in some ways you've
said that that's
i guess i'm doing the right thing
learning science backs me up the um
i mean depends what i was pondering i
sometimes probably don't know the right
things
but um what you what's you oh actually
there's a bunch of uh
questions here uh from youtube suresh
jai says what is khan academy's goal and
what are the best strategy for learning
at night
i could take part of that but maybe you
could start with the what's the best
it's related to what we're talking about
is there anything specific about night
that we should be thinking about the the
biggest things aren't really the
the time of day but how much cognitive
effort you have to put into something
and so if you have to study at night you
have to study at night but the things
you should do or think about how can you
clear out other distractions make sure
it's quiet so you have the most
cognitive energy that you have available
to focusing on the thing you need to
focus on
and so you know at the end of the day if
it's been a long day and you're kind of
running on fumes you might think about
how to how to get a little more of that
and even if it's a 15 15-minute nap
before you start
that can be a good thing to think about
you know how do you get that focus
back that you that you need yeah no
you know that's very close to what i
would say and you know part of this fun
of this conversation might be i will say
things and then you will tell me whether
that is in no way sound sound advice
or actually sal there's three studies
that say exactly what you're so so you
you
but but what i found especially in
college when
you had some things that were a little
bit hard you know i remember some of
those more advanced math courses
there'd be a question and i just look at
i was like i don't even know how to
approach this
i actually learned to delegate to my
subconscious and i know this sounds a
little bit weird
but you know just as if you are a
manager if you're an executive at a
company if you're a leader
you can't do everything yourself you
have to delegate to your team and
oftentimes you don't want to micromanage
your team that's disempowering
i realize that we all we're kind of like
this consciousness that sits on this
massive computing machine or whatever
you want to call it an inferential
engine which is our brains
and i learned that if i look at the
problem and i think deeply about it i do
struggle a little bit i tried to make a
little headway in it
but then i go to sleep it's eerie how i
sometimes
wake up in the morning and it's like a
delivery
um of like oh this is the answer cell i
was like oh thank you subconscious
i will go write that down and take
credit for it even though
even though even though it was uh it
actually happened recently on a much
more
i was i was like who's what who's the
lead singer of the eagles and i and i
went back to the house like who's the
lead singer and then i woke up in the
morning and i was like don henley
so the brain the brain the brain
definitely
um you'll hear lots of people talk about
also like say i do my best thinking when
i'm walking the dog
or when i'm in the shower and it's
because you're kind of
again not putting all of your focus on
it but letting
it be kind of working in the background
there and
um there's lots of folks that have that
same experience in different ways
whether it's sleeping or
just taking a break and thinking about
something else um for a little while
that'll
help you actually then be stronger at
the thing you were targeting to do
right right i think so many times you
just feel like you need to power through
things
not sleep take you know drink caffeine
and
maybe on the margin but
not really long term is that a good
thing not really is that a good solution
and that kind of ties into the other
thing that is
if there's one you know one of the big
findings that's just replicated over and
over and over again
is try to space out your studying trying
to cram it all in that night before
like you said you might do okay if the
on the test the next day
but if you've got to then do it on the
midterm or the final
it's not going to be there anymore
whereas if you space it out
use the same amount of time you know if
you're studying for two hours a night if
instead you do 20 minutes
over time each night for six nights
you're going to remember it better than
if you don't just cram those two hours
in the night before
so that does take some planning it does
mean you've got to be a little bit more
planful in your life about where you
start putting things in
but we do find that um learners who
learn more
are able to retain it for a longer
period of time
do that more space practice we call it
yeah yeah no it's consistent you know
you you building that habit
you know 20 minutes a day whatever and
to the other part of that question about
what's
purpose of khan academy for those who
don't know we're not for profit
mission-free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and it really is
to help all of you whether you're
working independently but
ideally working in conjunction with a
teacher to have access to material that
is
engaging that you can learn at your own
time and pace that teachers can
understand what your needs are better
uh and and you can fill in any gaps and
and really accelerate your learning so
that's a
the elevator pitch of khan academy for
those to that to that question
so this is a question from facebook
robin schwartz asks
how can we help people enjoy studying
perhaps the same way people enjoy
training for a marathon
thanks from robin the math lady
whoo the math lady i'd like to know more
about what she does
but uh but so there's a number of things
that you can think about that make
things
enjoyable or interesting or motivating
so first in terms of of motivation we
find that there's a couple things that
make people find motivating one if you
have some expectation that you're going
to be successful
you're going to be more likely to do
something so that idea is that you know
if
if i know if i spend three hours on this
i'm still going to fail
that's not going to motivate me to try
to do this at all
and so that kind of thinking about what
that is and so this ties in a lot to
what you hear about the research on
growth versus fixed mindset and i know
you've had angela duckworth on talking
about grit which is kind of a longer
term
piece of this but on the shorter term if
you think about just understanding that
with practice you can get better at all
kinds of things including math including
science
so that expectation of success and think
about how you frame
how you talk to yourself about whether
you're likely to be successful or not
so that's one piece of it thinking you
know what i
am likely to experience success if i put
some hard work into this
and then the the second piece is is
adding value to it is this something
that's valuable to you and so things can
be valuable
in a lot of ways i know just from
talking to you you are a very curious
person and i think you find
value just in learning new things but
other people i think sometimes find
that they it needs to be related to
their life so they want to see how it's
going to be related to
a hobby or a job that they might need or
they want to think about
how is this going to be related to
thinking about
another course you might be interested
in taking that you need this to be able
to be successful in that course
so thinking about what is the value of
this and
what can it what can it help you do and
provide by learning this knowledge and
skills that's the second piece
but then robin suggests thinking about
like training for a marathon and a lot
of
uh exercise training these days is
actually
much more about you've got your fitbit
you've got your
graphs your tracking your progress
you're thinking about how you're doing
and how all of those kind of fit
together and with those pieces
we can also think about are there ways
that we can use those kind of motivators
to help
make studying more enjoyable and so at
con there are things like
energy points that you get by
watching videos you get them by
increasing your mastery on skills
you can think about charting your own
progress
on those skills that you've mastered and
thinking about
how that then builds into what you know
so you can tie in that system
to also the value that you see so if you
if you think those kinds of things are
motivating for you to be able to
kind of see your progress and work
through it those kind of things are
available to think about how you track
your progress on learning
um over time and things like kind of can
help you do that
that's super useful and and just to
throw in my own two cents that are not
as backed up by research but just
personal experience which is
i i've said this before you know you
could view like oh i've gotta slog
through this chapter of the book and
memorize some stuff or
you could tell yourself we live in this
mystery called the universe
like someone probably many hundreds of
people's life work
went into the culmination of knowledge
not the combination it's a
long journey but the the knowledge that
i can now read in a textbook
or or get on khan academy or some other
resource um
this is powerful like i can like you
know newton would have done anything
to be able to read this chapter and i
get to read it now so that's one and and
it does tell you about how the universe
works no matter
you know we can all have our subjects
that we connect with and then our
subjects were like oh
i guess this is a requirement i got it
but if you have the opposite mindset if
you say no eve
every subject has something that is deep
inside of it you know i think about when
you look at these movies like or these
books like harry potter right like we
all imagine
going on these adventures where we
encounter some book and it is cryptic
and it is hard to but there are spells
in that book
and if you can get through the cryptic
nature of it
you are going to understand something
about the universe and be able to
manipulate the universe
in very powerful ways and i think
you could do the same things in your
study you're learning an organic
chemistry mechanism you're like oh i got
to memorize the aldol reactions like no
the aldol reaction has wisdom in it and
if you really understand it it's going
to unlock other things and you're even
going to be able to take it into other
parts of your life but anyway
i think the more you always imagine
yourself that you're in some form of an
epic adventure which in theory we are in
this kind of who knows what um
things become more interesting that's
pretty cool and
that i actually have done in my past a
bunch of research on games
in games and learning and one of the key
things
you know people all the time when they
think about games think about oh we're
going to earn points and all that
one of the things that actually is
really attractive to people about
playing games is the quest
the going and the searching and the you
know
seeing where the quest takes you and
leads you and that's kind of what you're
talking about too of
the adventure of getting there exactly
exactly and when you're when those you
know when
whoever it is you know hermione
encounters some
old spell book she's like oh i gotta
read this she's her mind you've got the
example of the person who does like to
study but
anyway i mean there's a bunch of
questions coming in i mean but
i'll ask a general question relative to
khan academy you know
christian and we've obviously talked a
lot about this but
where do you think khan academy where do
you think it fits in
in the learning process and you know
related to that
on youtube nikhil governor asks i mean
says hi sal but really hi both of us
you know why do you believe in the
mastery approach to learning so yeah i
mean kind of painting a picture where
does khan academy fit in what does it do
well what
where does the in-person classroom mean
a lot like what's your what are your
thoughts there
and and what is research one of the
one of the reasons i was excited to join
khan academy was actually
because of the ways that it can serve
as a supplement to everything else that
goes on in the classroom
and so when we think about what that
means as a supplement
we want to do a couple of different
things so one thing that happens with a
curriculum or with a teacher teaching a
classroom is sometimes
the explanation just doesn't quite make
sense you don't quite get it but having
someone else explain it in a slightly
different way
it gives you that aha moment of oh yeah
now i get it
so that's one thing certainly with the
videos that happen
a lot and it's one place to think about
just getting an alternative explanation
of what's going on
and then the second piece that we know
is so important for learning is to be
able to practice
with feedback and very often there's
maybe a problem set in the back of the
book with the you know the odd number
answers
that just have the answer so there's
this whole problem when you turn to the
you're like i don't know how to do this
you turn to the back of the book and it
says
62. you're like i don't know
what to make of that um and so khan
academy provides both
the ability to have additional practice
but also to have some supports in doing
it so having some hints to get you
unstuck
and then once you get to an answer
giving you feedback about whether that
was right and why or why not it was
right
um so that's really important to the to
the learning process and where things
are
the bigger question is then that all of
that fits into
this idea of mastery learning which um i
know you've explained on
on various times but for folks that
aren't familiar is the idea that
you you work on mastering or getting
up to proficiency on a given piece of
knowledge or skill
before you keep going on to the next one
in most of our traditional education you
just
move forward to the next skill and next
skill whether you've mastered the last
one or not
and we end up with kind of these holes
in learning
um and so what we can do with mastery
learning is say we're going to focus
instead of making sure you go
all everyone in lockstep and say we're
going to make sure you master this skill
and then we'll go on to the next skill
and the next skill
and the the research behind that is
that um that leads to large impacts on
learning
so this is actually something that
particularly in the 70s and the 80s was
studied extensively like hundreds of
studies
and um so then there's been these
studies that bring and try to summarize
all of those studies
and they pretty and they consistently
find that that effect of
mastering something getting testing say
do i know this
if i don't i go back and learn it more
and deeper
and then test again and then when i'm
ready to go on that that sequence
is really powerful and leads to large
impacts on learning outcomes
and what's your sense given that there
is this you know fairly large body of
research
i think there's few things with that
much data backing
uh backing it up why has it i mean as
you mentioned a lot of these studies
were in the 70s or 80s and you know
we've even talked a hundred years ago in
winnetka illinois they were doing some
essentially mastery learning why isn't
in your sense
kind of the mainstream way of learning
today
well our systems aren't set up to do
this so if you think about a classroom
even with 30 kids much less a school
with hundreds of kids
how do you have everyone go at their own
pace like it's not scalable
it's not how we can then educate a whole
bunch of
learners so that's the the beauty of a
supplement like khan academy is we can
think about how to create a hybrid
approach
where students are keeping up at grade
level
and that's important we know for
students to be able to make progress and
get to eventually where they need to be
but at the same time they can be filling
their gaps in between
so that they are not having those those
big holes in the swiss cheese that they
don't know how to
that they inhibit them from them
learning the new content so i think
in order to be able to work in the
system we have with schools
with learners we need to think about how
that hybrid approach comes together yeah
that makes makes sense
you know there's a question here from
facebook mona lisa carr and this is i
think a question a lot of people are
asking right now
how can the engagement of students be
done now that the online classes are
here to stay
and be the and are the new norm how can
we make their learning more effective so
yeah i mean this is a big question right
now
it sure is i think first i would say
do not just try to replicate everything
we did in
the in school classroom in a digital
environment instead think about
all right what are our main goals and
how can we use the digital environment
in maybe new ways to help us get there
so if you think about what things the
digital world lets us
do it lets us potentially set up
problems and scenarios that are more
in depth and we can think about for
instance simulations
that allow us to simulate things that
maybe
we can't even see in the real world or
let us try things that would be really
dangerous in the real world
um and so thinking about how we can take
advantage
of what the digital world lets us do to
do
kind of some fun and interesting things
that keep
students engaged and motivated um i
think is the approach we need to take
instead of saying how can we just
you know move what we've done before and
put it in the new place
yeah no that makes sense and i'll just
add you know i think
even in in-person classrooms the more
interactive it is the better and you
know you've
people heard me go off about you know
300 lecture halls
just a lecture don't really make a lot
of sense uh but that's that much more
important in a digital environment
because obviously if if someone just
lectures to someone for
60 minutes in a digital environment that
might as well be a video and frankly
that should have been chunked up into
you know five six minute long videos so
when you're on the zoom or google meet
the more
interactive it can be where you're able
to pull students out
and maybe there is to your point you
know you could maybe do shorter sessions
but we'll do it with smaller groups of
students
let them you know their khan academy is
valuable for the asynchronous where kids
can learn their own time and pace do the
mastery learning
teachers can monitor and that way when
they go synchronous on
zoom or whatever else or in the
classroom ideally
they can go deeper and some kids can
continue to work at their own time pace
while some kids get a much more
highly focused intervention at a ratio
that is normally hard to do to your
points
normally you're getting a 30 to one one
pace fits all and
some kids are lost some kids are bored
um
and no one really feels that personal
attention but obviously in a class of 30
15 could work on something else while 15
get a deeper a deep dive on something
they need
yeah and what you've talked about that
difference between active and passive is
another one of those
big big fundamental things in learning
science so there's actually something
that's called the icap framework i see
ap
and as you go from
through it you can think about the
impact on learning so the p
is passive that's like just sitting
there watching a video doing nothing
so that's going to have the least amount
of impact on learning
and then from there you can think about
active so i'm actually
you know answering questions and doing
something then the c
stands for constructing and that just
means i'm actually creating something
and so if i'm having to do all of the
creation and thinking about where that
is that's going to be even more
impactful on learning
and finally the eye is interactive and
that's interacting with other people
about the content
and that's the most powerful thing you
can do so if we think about
the availability of video conferencing
many of them have the capability of
doing small groups so how can instead of
thinking
the video conferencing is a way for me
to re do my lecture
to all of you how can i break you into
small groups and have you
talk about the content instead of
thinking about it as a trend one way
transmission of what we're doing
so as you think about what do we know
about learning
and how can we then help use the digital
tools
to help us take advantage of those
pieces i think that's going to give the
strongest results in this
new world we're in yeah or any world
we're in frankly but it's that much more
important
that much more important to your point
uh
what you know these conversations always
go faster but luckily kristen we're
we're
part of the same team so we'll have you
on many times uh
maybe just finish you know what are your
people have heard me talk about my hopes
and dreams for khan academy you know
even at a high level as an institution
but also sometimes as a
as an experience you know what are your
hopes
for khan academy at least and especially
from a learning science point of view
but but really
on any dimension yeah no i think
definitely most of them are related to
the learning science point of view
although
the the overall vision of a you know
world-class free education for
anyone anywhere is pretty amazing um but
i think the piece that then i can
contribute to that
is thinking about how do we make the
the most of this idea of being a
key supplemental resource how can we
best
take advantage of mastery learning and
help teachers do that in the classroom
in ways that
flow easily for them and that are become
just then
another part of how they teach and then
as that pieces we become think about how
we can be integrated
into classrooms and and help support
teachers in
being able to scale that idea of mastery
learning
then the next piece becomes how can we
also think about
these ideas of being more active and
encouraging activity
how do we provide resources to help
teachers do that
both with khan academy and if khan
academy is helping
the teachers do more of the practice and
the feedback
how can teachers then have more time to
do
more of the potentially constructive and
interactive things that they might be
able to do
so i see us becoming a just a trusted
supplement that helps teachers overall
teach in the ways that they want to
teach
and help learners be able to get those
better learning outcomes that they're
going to get to
yeah no we're excited i'm excited to do
it with you hopefully and then the whole
whole team here at khan academy
uh thanks so much for for joining
kristin thank you sal it's pleasure to
be here
so thanks everyone for for joining today
uh i do
you know uh there's so many dimensions
to talk about these days
we actually are going to have tomorrow
two live streams
um uh one we're going to have at 8 30 in
the morning pacific
time which is 11 30 eastern time with
bill lewis who's the co-chair of lazard
lazard the investment bank and you know
he's gonna talk about his life journey
and also just talk about
you know the really important question
of race in america and
all of this energy that um is out there
right now how does it get channeled so
that we
you know as a society we move forward um
so that's going to be a really
fascinating conversation and then
tomorrow at our regular time we're going
to have governor jeb bush
uh to talk you know when we scheduled
governor bush it was
really to talk about things like covet
and the economy and we're going to
and education uh governor bush is very
active in the education space as is bill
lewis
uh and then we're going to uh you know
obviously also talk about some of the
same themes about what's going on in the
country right now so
uh you have a double feature of of our
live stream
tomorrow some really important questions
and once again what makes this
interesting is you have a chance to ask
these very
knowledgeable and interesting folks
questions uh so please join us tomorrow
i'll see you then
you